[Musik]
wir wurden heute um 6 Uhr von der
Tagwache geweckt und es ging sofort los
es ist auf jeden Fall was anderes als
der normale Wecker vom
[Musik]
Handy nachdem wir am ersten Tag den
bürrokratischen Teil erledigt haben
gingen wir rüber in die
begleidungskammer um unser Gewand
auszufassen das war wirklich viel also
hätte ich mir nicht
[Musik]
gedacht dann waren wir bei der
ärstlichen Untersuchung wo einfach
geschaut wird ob wir körperlich fit sind
und ob man vielleicht drogenommen hat
oder sämtliche
Sachen das Essen hat mich sehr
überrascht es schmeckt besser erwartet
in der mil hab wir auch ein großes
Buffet mit viel
Auswahl sind Herter als was ich erwartet
habe aber ich denke das ist auch gut um
uns fit zu
[Musik]
machen geh zmer Z für alle die am Gang
stehen und kein Bad
tragen
rasieren
jerasiert das het coverlich oder das
heißt der gendlich oder hat
schonier sehr
[Musik]
gut wir wollen den he nutzen inen die
waffelich zu übergeben als highight kann
ich auf jeden Fall die feliche
waffenübergabe aufzählen als meine Waffe
übergeben wurde das war echt ein
bedeutsamer Moment alles in allen war
die Woche hart aber ich bin stolz ein
Teil dieses zu
[Musik]
sein